- Selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya adalah direktur teknis
Pendidikan di IBM Quantum.
Ini adalah pelajaran kedua dari seri ini. Kalau kamu belum
nonton pelajaran pertama, pastikan kamu cek dulu ya.
Kita akan langsung membangun dari apa yang kita bahas
di pelajaran pertama, jadi penting buat kamu ngerti
materi itu sebelum masuk ke pelajaran ini.
Juga, perlu diketahui bahwa seri ini
mencakup konten buku teks selain video, dan kamu bisa nemuin link
ke konten buku teks itu
di deskripsi video. Ini adalah pelajaran dua dari
unit satu seri ini.
Unit satu membahas dasar-dasar
informasi kuantum.
Di pelajaran sebelumnya, kita ngomongin informasi kuantum dalam konteks sistem tunggal, artinya kita punya satu
sistem yang menyimpan informasi
dan kita menggambarkan bagaimana
cara kerjanya secara terpisah.
Kita udah menghabiskan cukup banyak waktu
untuk informasi klasik, terutama buat membangun titik referensi dan menyoroti kesamaan matematis
antara informasi kuantum dan klasik.
Kita juga udah liat bagaimana keadaan kuantum bisa direpresentasikan oleh vektor, khususnya vektor yang punya
entri bilangan kompleks dan norma Euclidean sama dengan satu,
dan kita udah bahas pengukuran basis standar
dan operasi uniter.
Di pelajaran ini, kita bakal memperluas pandangan kita ke beberapa sistem, yang masing-masing mampu
menyimpan informasi kuantum.
Ini bukan sekadar soal bilang bahwa setiap sistem individu
bekerja seperti yang kita bahas terakhir kali, ada suatu pengertian di mana keseluruhan
lebih besar dari jumlah bagian-bagiannya, dan itu juga berlaku untuk
informasi klasik ketika probabilitas terlibat.
Beberapa sistem bisa
berinteraksi satu sama lain dan bisa berkorelasi
satu sama lain misalnya, dan dalam konteks kuantum, ini mencakup kemungkinan
bahwa sistem-sistem itu saling entangle, yang merupakan istilah yang mungkin
pernah kamu dengar sebelumnya.
Entanglement adalah fenomena yang sangat
penting dalam informasi kuantum dan kita akan banyak membahasnya seiring seri ini berlanjut.
Ada prinsip sederhana namun demikian, yang memberi kita banyak kemudahan untuk berpikir dan
memahami informasi kuantum untuk beberapa sistem,
dan itu adalah bahwa kita selalu bisa
mengambil dua atau lebih sistem dan menggabungkannya atau sekadar secara konseptual
memikirkannya bersama-sama
dan memandangnya seolah-olah mereka membentuk
satu sistem gabungan.
Dan ketika kita memikirkan
sistem gabungan seperti ini, seolah-olah itu satu sistem, kita menyadari bahwa itu harus dideskripsikan dengan cara yang konsisten
dengan semua yang kita pelajari
di pelajaran sebelumnya tentang sistem tunggal.
Kita akan lihat bagaimana ini bekerja
dan bagaimana deskripsi informasi kuantum
dari beberapa sistem muncul cukup alami dari cara kerjanya untuk sistem tunggal
berdasarkan satu prinsip ini. Ini adalah gambaran umum pelajaran dan kebetulan identik dengan gambaran umum pelajaran sebelumnya,
tapi kali ini fokus kita
akan pada beberapa sistem alih-alih sistem tunggal.
Sama seperti yang kita lakukan di pelajaran sebelumnya dan untuk alasan yang sama persis, kita akan mulai dengan
informasi klasik.
Sekali lagi, kita akan melihat
kesamaan yang sangat dekat antara cara kerja informasi kuantum
dan klasik di tingkat matematis.
Kita biasanya tidak akan terlalu banyak fokus
pada informasi klasik atau memulai setiap pelajaran dalam seri ini dengan informasi klasik seperti ini.
Pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya akan cenderung jauh lebih fokus secara eksklusif pada informasi dan komputasi kuantum.
Tapi di sini di awal
ini adalah pendekatan yang masuk akal dan kembali pada gagasan bahwa memikirkan informasi klasik
bisa menjadi sumber panduan yang berharga untuk memahami informasi kuantum.
Kita juga akan membahas
konsep penting dari tensor product di
bagian pelajaran ini.
Tensor product sangat penting dalam informasi kuantum, tapi mereka juga muncul dalam
konteks klasik.
Kemudian kita akan beralih ke informasi kuantum dan seperti di pelajaran sebelumnya kita akan membahas keadaan kuantum,
pengukuran basis standar,
dan operasi uniter kali ini
untuk beberapa sistem.
Kita akan mulai dengan membahas
keadaan klasik dari beberapa sistem.
Ingat dari pelajaran sebelumnya bahwa keadaan klasik suatu sistem adalah
konfigurasi sistem itu yang bisa dikenali dan
dideskripsikan dengan jelas
tanpa ketidakpastian atau kesalahan apapun. Dan dalam istilah matematis, ketika kita menyebut himpunan keadaan klasik,
kita hanya maksudkan himpunan yang terhingga dan tidak kosong.
Kita akan mulai pembahasan
beberapa sistem dengan mengasumsikan bahwa kita punya
hanya dua sistem X dan Y.
X punya sejumlah himpunan keadaan klasik yang akan kita sebut sigma sama
seperti di pelajaran sebelumnya, dan Y punya sejumlah himpunan keadaan klasik
yang akan kita sebut gamma. Himpunan sigma dan gamma
bisa jadi himpunan yang sama atau bisa berbeda,
tapi kita memberi mereka nama yang berbeda, tidak hanya karena mereka
bisa jadi himpunan yang berbeda, tapi juga karena itu akan membantu
kita menjaga kejelasan jika kita memberi mereka nama yang berbeda.
Kita akan menemukan bahwa cukup
mudah untuk menggeneralisasi seluruh pembahasan ini dari dua sistem ke berapa pun jumlah sistem, tapi
dengan memulai dari dua sistem,
kita bisa fokus pada ide-ide fundamental tanpa terjebak dalam detail.
WEBVTT
Sekarang, bayangkan kita
menempatkan X dan Y berdampingan dengan X di kiri dan Y di kanan, dan kita memandang dua sistem ini bersama
seolah-olah mereka membentuk satu sistem gabungan.
Untuk memberi nama pada sistem baru ini, kita bisa menulisnya sebagai
pasangan terurut seperti ini, atau kita bisa sekadar menjuxtaposisi
dua huruf seperti ini.
Keduanya umum dan kita
bisa memilih mana yang kita mau atau mana yang lebih nyaman.
Bagaimanapun, kita akan membacanya sebagai XY.
Pertanyaan yang sangat alami
untuk diajukan pada titik ini adalah apa saja keadaan klasik dari sistem gabungan baru XY ini?
Dan jawabannya adalah bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik dari XY adalah Cartesian product dari
dua himpunan keadaan klasik,
sigma dan gamma, yang bisa
kamu lihat didefinisikan tepat di sini.
Pada suatu momen, X punya suatu keadaan klasik
yang merupakan elemen dari sigma, dan Y punya suatu keadaan klasik
yang merupakan elemen dari gamma,
dan kita sekadar memikirkan
dua keadaan ini bersama seolah-olah mereka membentuk satu keadaan, dan itulah tepat nosinya
yang ditangkap oleh Cartesian product. Kita punya dua elemen,
satu dari masing-masing himpunan kita, dan kita ingin memikirkan
dua elemen ini bersama
seolah-olah mereka membentuk satu
elemen dari satu himpunan.
Untuk jelasnya, ada asumsi di sini yaitu kita tahu
mana di antara sistem kita yang X dan mana yang Y,
dan tidak ada kebingungan di antara mereka. Tidak penting bahwa X secara fisik berada di sisi kiri
dan Y di kanan,
melainkan bahwa kedua
sistem itu bisa dibedakan dan kita telah memutuskan
untuk mengurutkan mereka dengan cara ini hanya supaya kita bisa menjaga
mana yang mana.
Ini adalah contoh yang sangat sederhana di mana sigma adalah alfabet biner dan gamma adalah himpunan
yang berisi empat jenis kartu.
Jika X menyimpan nilai biner dan Y menyimpan salah satu dari empat jenis kartu, maka ada delapan
kemungkinan keadaan klasik
dari pasangan XY, yang bisa
kamu lihat terdaftar tepat di sini.
Untuk lebih dari dua sistem, ini menggeneralisasi dengan cara yang langsung.
Khususnya jika X1 hingga Xn adalah sistem-sistem yang punya himpunan keadaan klasik sigma satu hingga sigma n masing-masing.
Kemudian jika kita membayangkan mengelompokkan
n sistem bersama dan memandangnya sebagai satu sistem, himpunan keadaan klasiknya diberikan oleh Cartesian product
dari n himpunan keadaan klasik
sigma satu hingga sigma n.
Seperti yang bisa kamu lihat tepat di sini di layar. Cartesian product
bisa didefinisikan seperti ini untuk berapa pun jumlah himpunan.
Misalnya, jika kita punya tiga sistem dan semuanya berbagi alfabet biner sebagai himpunan keadaan klasik mereka, jadi dengan kata lain kita punya tiga bit,
maka ada delapan
kemungkinan keadaan klasik dari tiga bit yang dipandang
bersama sebagai satu sistem dan kamu bisa melihatnya terdaftar tepat di sini.
Setiap sistem secara individual bisa
berada dalam keadaan nol atau satu, dan kita merentangi semua
kemungkinan kombinasinya.
Sebuah n-tuple keadaan klasik bisa juga ditulis sebagai string di mana kita menghilangkan
tanda kurung dan koma seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan ini sangat masuk akal ketika kita memikirkan
keadaan klasik sebagai simbol seperti dalam contoh yang sangat umum
dari alfabet biner
yang terus kita kembalikan. Terkadang sangat nyaman untuk melakukan ini dan cenderung membuat
ekspresi kita lebih sederhana
dan lebih bersih. Gagasan tentang string sebenarnya diformalkan
dalam istilah matematis melalui Cartesian product,
jadi ini sebenarnya hanya
notasi alternatif dan bukan sesuatu yang secara konseptual berbeda.
Sebagai contoh, katakanlah kita punya
10 bit X1 hingga X10.
Itu berarti bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik dari 10 bit bersama,
yang mungkin kamu bayangkan secara natural sebagai register 10 bit
dalam komputer misalnya,
adalah Cartesian product sepuluh kali lipat
dari alfabet biner dengan dirinya sendiri.
Dan jika kita menulis keadaan-keadaan itu seperti string, mereka tampak seperti yang kamu lihat
di sini, ada 1.024 dari mereka,
jadi tentu saja tidak semua terdaftar di sini. Tiga titik ini
dimaksudkan untuk menunjukkan bahwa ada pola yang bisa kamu simpulkan
dan semoga kamu paham. Sekarang ada konvensi
yang akan kita ikuti untuk mengurutkan elemen
dari himpunan Cartesian product,
dan penting untuk
mengklarifikasi ini demi merepresentasikan baik keadaan probabilistik maupun keadaan kuantum sebagai vektor.
Konvensinya adalah bahwa
kita mengurutkan elemen dari himpunan Cartesian product
secara leksikografis, yang pada dasarnya hanya
berarti pengurutan kamus.
Lebih spesifiknya, kita mulai dengan asumsi bahwa setiap himpunan individual yang kita ambil Cartesian product-nya sudah punya urutannya sendiri
dan kita memikirkan
n-tuple atau string tertentu seolah-olah itu sebuah kata dan kita
mengurutkannya secara alfabetis.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah bahwa posisi dalam
sebuah n-tuple atau string menurun signifikansinya
dari kiri ke kanan,
sama seperti ketika kita menulis angka menggunakan digit nol sampai sembilan.
Ini adalah contoh yang
dimaksudkan untuk mengklarifikasi hal ini.
Jika kita mengambil Cartesian product antara himpunan yang berisi
satu, dua, dan tiga dan alfabet biner, kita mendapatkan himpunan yang berisi enam elemen
dan di sini mereka terdaftar dalam
urutan yang sedang dijelaskan.
Semua elemen dengan
satu di posisi pertama datang sebelum semua elemen dengan dua di posisi pertama dan mereka datang sebelum semua elemen
WEBVTT
dengan tiga di posisi pertama. Dan setiap kali dua elemen
sepakat di posisi pertama, kita jatuh kembali pada urutan
di posisi kedua.
Jadi itulah urutan yang
kita gunakan untuk Cartesian product.
Perhatikan bahwa ketika kita menggunakan konvensi ini dan kita menulis n-tuple sebagai string, kita mengamati beberapa pola yang sangat familiar.
Misalnya, Cartesian product dari
alfabet biner dengan dirinya sendiri diurutkan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
dan kamu bisa memikirkan string-string ini sebagai diurutkan secara numeris jika kamu mengambil string-string ini
sebagai encoding biner dari bilangan bulat non-negatif dan ini menggeneralisasi
ke panjang string berapa pun. Beralih ke keadaan probabilistik, kita sudah tahu dari pelajaran sebelumnya
bahwa keadaan probabilistik mengaitkan suatu probabilitas dengan setiap keadaan klasik
dari sistem tertentu.
Jika kita punya sistem gabungan di mana kita telah mengambil dua atau lebih sistem dan kita memandangnya secara kolektif seolah-olah mereka membentuk satu
sistem seperti yang baru saja kita bahas,
maka keadaan probabilistik
dari sistem gabungan ini harus menetapkan probabilitas ke elemen-elemen dari Cartesian product
dari sistem-sistem individual,
himpunan keadaan klasik. Itulah karena itulah
himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem gabungan.
Misalnya, dengan mengasumsikan
bahwa X dan Y adalah bit, kita punya contoh ini dari
keadaan probabilistik XY.
Probabilitas bahwa kedua
bit bernilai nol adalah setengah dan probabilitas bahwa kedua
bit bernilai satu adalah setengah, jadi kedua bit tidak pernah berbeda.
Itu adalah keadaan probabilistik yang valid dari XY, dan kita bisa juga
menulisnya sebagai vektor
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini dan di sini kamu bisa melihat bahwa kita
mengikuti konvensi yang saya jelaskan tadi untuk mengurutkan keadaan-keadaan klasik ini.
Ini adalah contoh dari
keadaan probabilistik di mana X dan Y berkorelasi, dan inilah pengertian di mana keseluruhan
lebih besar dari jumlah bagian-bagiannya. Seperti yang saya sarankan sebelumnya, tidak serta-merta bahwa kita
punya keadaan probabilistik
dari X dan keadaan probabilistik dari Y dan kita menggabungkannya, melainkan kita pertama kali menggabungkan
sistem-sistemnya
dan kemudian kita memikirkan
keadaan probabilistik dari sistem gabungan.
Untuk lebih tepat mengenai
korelasi antar sistem. Kita mulai dengan mendefinisikan
gagasan tentang independensi, yang pada dasarnya adalah
ketiadaan korelasi.
Di sini omong-omong, istilah independensi mengacu
pada independensi statistik sebagai lawan dari independensi linear
dari vektor misalnya.
Itu adalah gagasan fundamental dalam
probabilitas dan statistik.
Jika kita punya dua sistem X dan Y dan kita punya suatu keadaan probabilistik
dari XY dalam pikiran, maka kita mengatakan bahwa X dan Y independen.
Jika rumus yang
kamu lihat di sini benar untuk setiap pilihan keadaan klasik
a dan b dari X dan Y.
Salah satu cara untuk menginterpretasikan
kondisi independensi ini adalah bahwa itu menyatakan bahwa probabilitas bagi X untuk berada dalam satu keadaan klasik tertentu
dan probabilitas bagi Y untuk berada dalam beberapa keadaan klasik lainnya sama sekali tidak ada
hubungannya satu sama lain.
Jadi, mengetahui keadaan
salah satu sistem tidak memengaruhi
probabilitas yang terkait dengan keadaan sistem lainnya.
Jika kamu membayangkan memilih secara acak
beberapa keadaan klasik dari X sesuai prosedur tertentu dan kemudian memilih secara acak
beberapa keadaan klasik dari Y
sesuai prosedur lain yang sama sekali tidak
terhubung dengan yang untuk X, misalnya jika satu orang melempar koin
dan orang lain di
ruangan yang berbeda melempar dadu, maka inilah rumus
yang akan kamu gunakan untuk mendapatkan probabilitas
untuk berbagai kombinasi
keadaan yang muncul. Inti dari definisi ini adalah bahwa independensi adalah
ketika rumusnya berlaku.
Ketika kita memikirkan keadaan probabilistik dalam hal vektor probabilitas, ada formulasi sederhana
dari kondisi ini
khususnya jika kita punya
keadaan probabilistik dari XY, yang bisa kita nyatakan sebagai
vektor dalam notasi bra-ket
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini. Kemudian untuk mengatakan bahwa X dan Y independen adalah sama dengan adanya
dua vektor probabilitas,
ket Phi dan ket Psi yang omong-omong bisa kita
baca saja sebagai Phi dan Psi demi singkatnya yang merepresentasikan
keadaan probabilistik dari X dan Y secara terpisah yang memenuhi persamaan ini
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Untuk semua pilihan a dan b, itu pada dasarnya merupakan
pengungkapan ulang dari definisi dalam hal vektor.
Misalnya, ini adalah keadaan probabilistik
dari sepasang bit XY di mana X dan Y independen.
Kondisi yang
diperlukan untuk independensi berlaku untuk vektor-vektor
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Yaitu probabilitas
untuk setiap kemungkinan pengaturan untuk dua bit diberikan oleh produk dari probabilitas yang sesuai
untuk bit-bit individual.
Misalnya, probabilitas untuk kedua
bit mengambil nilai nol adalah sama dengan seperenam, yang sama dengan satu
per empat kali dua per tiga,
dan begitu juga untuk
tiga kemungkinan lainnya yang bisa dicek satu per satu.
Untuk keadaan probabilistik yang kita lihat sebelumnya di sisi lain di mana kita
punya dua bit yang selalu sepakat dan mengambil nilai nol dan
satu dengan probabilitas setengah
kita tidak punya independensi dan itulah mengapa kita mengatakan bahwa
bit-bit tersebut berkorelasi.
Korelasi sekadar berarti
ketiadaan independensi.
Cara sederhana untuk berargumen bahwa
dua bit tidak independen adalah dengan mengasumsikan bahwa mereka independen dan menurunkan kontradiksi
khususnya jika kedua
bit independen, harus ada
angka-angka q0, q1, r0 dan r1
WEBVTT
yang merepresentasikan probabilitas
untuk dua bit individual sehingga persamaan-persamaan
di sini terpenuhi.
Ini adalah probabilitas-probabilitas
yang berasal dari vektor kita dan ini adalah
persamaan-persamaan yang harus benar berdasarkan kondisi independensi,
tapi jika kita melihat
persamaan kedua ini di sini, kita melihat bahwa itu menuntut bahwa
q0 kali r1 sama dengan nol,
tapi satu-satunya cara agar
produk dari dua bilangan real bisa sama dengan nol adalah jika setidaknya satu dari
angka-angka itu sendiri sama dengan nol.
Ini kadang-kadang disebut
sifat produk nol dari bilangan real.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah bahwa produk dari dua bilangan real yang bukan nol
selalu bukan nol.
Jadi persamaan ini
di sini menyiratkan bahwa entah q0 sama dengan nol atau r1 sama dengan nol,
tapi dari persamaan pertama dan terakhir kita melihat bahwa tidak ada
dari dua alternatif itu yang bisa benar.
Jika q0 sama dengan nol, maka produk ini harus sama dengan nol, tapi tidak sama dengan nol
dan jika r1 sama dengan nol,
maka produk ini harus sama dengan nol, tapi itu juga tidak benar.
Jadi kita punya kontradiksi
dan kita menyimpulkan bahwa X dan Y tidak independen sehingga mereka berkorelasi.
Gagasan tentang independensi
yang baru saja kita bahas dan khususnya formulasinya dalam hal vektor probabilitas berkaitan erat
dengan operasi yang bisa
dilakukan pada vektor yang dikenal sebagai tensor product.
Tensor product bisa
didefinisikan tidak hanya untuk vektor tapi juga untuk matriks
dan sebenarnya gagasan tentang tensor product bisa didefinisikan
untuk banyak jenis
objek matematis lainnya juga.
Mereka bisa dideskripsikan
dengan cara yang cukup abstrak yang penting dan
berguna dalam matematika murni, tapi kita juga bisa mendefinisikan
tensor product untuk vektor
dengan cara yang sangat sederhana dan konkret, dan itulah jalur yang
akan kita ambil dalam pelajaran ini.
Jika kita punya dua vektor kolom Phi dan Psi yang ditulis dalam bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini di mana sigma dan gamma adalah pilihan
himpunan keadaan klasik manapun
yang kita suka atau indeks jika kamu lebih suka, maka tensor product dari vektor-vektor ini adalah vektor yang kamu lihat tepat di sini.
Kita merentangi semua elemen
dari Cartesian product dari dua himpunan, sigma dan gamma, dan entri dari vektor ini yang bersesuaian
dengan setiap pasangan ab, yang
ditulis sebagai string di sini, sama dengan produk dari entri-entri yang bersesuaian
dari dua vektor ini. Dengan kata lain, entri ab dari Phi tensor Psi adalah produk dari entri a
dari Phi dan entri b dari Psi,
dan itulah makna dari
apa yang ditulis di sini.
Pada dasarnya, ini adalah operasi yang sama yang baru saja kita lihat beberapa momen lalu ketika kita membahas independensi
dan sekarang kita hanya memberinya nama.
Ini adalah contoh yang sama persis
yang kita lihat tadi yang ditulis lebih eksplisit dalam
hal tensor product.
Sekali lagi, kita punya bahwa seperenam sama dengan satu per empat kali sepertiga, satu per dua belas sama dengan satu per empat
kali sepertiga dan seterusnya.
Di sini omong-omong ada
beberapa cara alternatif untuk menulis tensor product dari dua vektor.
Ketika kita menggunakan notasi bra-ket dan kita menulis dua ket berdampingan
seperti ini, itu berarti tensor product.
Jadi kamu bisa memikirkan tensor product sebagai semacam cara default untuk mengalikan dua vektor kolom bersama.
Tidak masuk akal
untuk memikirkan produk dari vektor kolom seperti ini dalam hal perkalian matriks karena dimensinya tidak cocok,
jadi tidak ada kekhawatiran
tentang ambiguitas di sini.
Kita juga bisa menulis
tensor product seperti ini di dalam sebuah ket dan itu berarti
hal yang persis sama.
Itu adalah tensor product
dari dua vektor.
Yang pertama sangat umum dan bahkan mungkin lebih umum untuk menulis tensor product seperti ini tanpa simbol tensor product
daripada menyertakan simbolnya. Yang kedua
jauh lebih jarang, tapi terkadang cukup membantu terutama
sebagai cara untuk menghilangkan kebutuhan
akan tanda kurung tambahan dalam situasi tertentu.
Kita juga bisa menyatakan
tensor product secara eksplisit dalam hal kolom aktual dari
angka-angka seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
jika kita mengambil tensor product dari dua vektor kolom di sini, maka inilah vektor yang kita dapatkan
dan kamu bisa melihat bahwa entri-entri di sini adalah produk dari entri-entri
yang berasal dari dua vektor ini.
Urutan entri-entri
dari tensor product konsisten dengan
definisi dari tadi asalkan kita mengikuti konvensi
yang saya jelaskan sebelumnya untuk mengurutkan elemen
dari himpunan Cartesian product.
Mengikuti konvensi itu setara dengan memikirkan
indeks dari vektor pertama sebagai
memiliki signifikansi yang lebih tinggi daripada indeks dari vektor kedua,
jadi kamu bisa melihat bahwa
saat kita melewati entri-entri dari tensor product, kita punya semua produk yang melibatkan entri pertama dari
vektor pertama di sebelah kiri,
yaitu alpha satu. Kemudian semua produk
yang melibatkan entri kedua dari vektor di sebelah kiri,
yaitu alpha dua dan seterusnya.
Ini adalah contoh di mana
vektor di sebelah kiri punya tiga entri dan vektor di
kanan punya empat entri sehingga kita bisa melihat lebih
jelas apa yang terjadi.
WEBVTT
Kita punya tiga entri dalam vektor pertama, jadi kita mulai dengan menuliskan tiga salinan dari vektor kedua dan kemudian kita mengalikan masing-masing salinan
dengan entri yang bersesuaian
dalam vektor pertama seperti ini.
Kita membawa alpha-alpha ke dalam seperti ini, dan di sini kita hanya
mengalikan vektor dengan skalar
dan akhirnya kita menghilangkan
tanda kurung dari salinan-salinan dan kita membentuk satu vektor kolom
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Sebagai catatan penting, perhatikan bahwa kita punya rumus-rumus berikut untuk tensor product dari
vektor-vektor basis standar.
Jika kita mengambil tensor product
dari ket a dan ket b, yang bisa kita tulis dengan
simbol tensor product atau tanpa, seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
maka hasilnya adalah sekadar ket ab.
Jika kita ingin menulis ab sebagai pasangan terurut alih-alih string, kita bisa melakukannya dan kita mendapatkan
ekspresi di sini,
tapi jauh lebih umum
untuk menulis ini di sini di mana kita menghilangkan tanda kurung
tapi kita menyisakan koma.
Ada pengertian di mana
yang satu dengan tanda kurung ini mungkin lebih benar, tapi ini adalah konvensi yang cukup standar dalam matematika
bahwa tanda kurung dihilangkan ketika tidak diperlukan atau tidak membantu.
Kamu bisa memikirkannya sebagai tersirat dalam yang satu ini di sini dan itu hanya lebih bersih
dan lebih nyaman dilihat.
Tensor product punya
sifat penting yaitu ia bersifat bilinear dan artinya itu bersifat linear
dalam masing-masing dari dua argumen asalkan yang lainnya tetap.
Lebih detailnya, ia
bersifat linear dalam argumen pertama yang dinyatakan oleh dua persamaan yang kamu lihat di sini,
yang pertama menyatakan bahwa
jika kita menjumlahkan dua vektor, Phi1 dan Phi2 dan kemudian mengambil
tensor product dengan Psi, kita mendapatkan hasil yang sama jika
kita mengambil tensor product
dengan Psi terlebih dahulu dan kemudian kita menjumlahkan.
Yang kedua menyatakan bahwa jika
kita mengalikan beberapa vektor Phi dengan beberapa skalar alpha dan kemudian kita mengambil
tensor product dengan Psi,
hasilnya sama seperti jika kita pertama mengambil tensor product dari Phi dan Psi dan kemudian kita mengalikan hasilnya dengan alpha.
Dan kita juga punya linearitas
dalam argumen kedua yang sama kecuali bahwa peran dari dua argumen tersebut ditukar.
Sifat bilinear ini
cukup mudah untuk diverifikasi dari definisi, tapi bagus untuk menulisnya seperti ini karena kita akan sering
menggunakan rumus-rumus ini.
Perhatikan omong-omong bahwa skalar mengalir bebas melalui tensor product dalam pengertian yang dinyatakan oleh
persamaan-persamaan yang kamu lihat di sini.
Yaitu tidak ada perbedaan
antara mengalikan argumen pertama dengan
skalar alpha dalam kasus ini mengalikan argumen kedua
dengan skalar itu
atau mengalikan keseluruhan
hal itu dengan skalar itu.
Persamaan-persamaan ini mengikuti dari
dua persamaan ini di sini dan karena tidak ada
perbedaan antara vektor-vektor ini, kita bisa menulis
ekspresi seperti yang kamu lihat di sini
tanpa tanda kurung karena
tidak ada kebutuhan untuk itu.
Mereka tidak menambah kejelasan
atau menghilangkan ambiguitas, jadi kita cukup menghilangkannya dan
kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang lebih bersih.
Semua ini menggeneralisasi
ke tiga atau lebih sistem.
Kita bisa mendefinisikan tensor product
dari tiga atau lebih vektor dengan menggeneralisasi rumus
untuk tensor product dari dua vektor dengan cara alami,
yang bisa kamu lihat dinyatakan di sini. Setiap entri dari tensor product diberikan oleh produk dari entri-entri yang bersesuaian
dari vektor-vektor yang kita
ambil tensor product-nya.
Cara yang setara untuk
mendefinisikan tensor product dari tiga atau lebih vektor
adalah dengan melakukannya secara rekursif yang pada akhirnya jatuh kembali pada definisi
dari tensor product antara dua vektor. Jadi jika n paling sedikit tiga, kita bisa memikirkan
tensor product dari n vektor
Phi1 hingga Phi n sebagai tensor product antara vektor apapun yang kita dapatkan dengan
mengambil tensor product dari n minus satu yang pertama dengan vektor terakhir,
dan jika kamu ingin tahu
apa tensor product dari n minus satu vektor pertama, kamu bisa menerapkan rumusnya
lagi jika n minus satu
paling sedikit tiga atau menggunakan definisi
dari sebelumnya jika n minus satu sama dengan dua.
Dua cara memikirkan
tensor product dari tiga atau lebih vektor adalah setara.
Kali ini ketika kita punya
tiga atau lebih vektor yang kita ambil tensor product-nya, kita tidak menggunakan istilah bilinear,
kita menggunakan istilah multilinear,
tapi idenya sama.
Tensor product bersifat linear
dalam masing-masing posisi asalkan vektor-vektor di
semua posisi lainnya
tetap. Beralih ke pengukuran
dari beberapa sistem dalam keadaan probabilistik,
kita segera mendapatkan spesifikasi tentang bagaimana pengukuran
bekerja untuk beberapa sistem dengan sekadar memikirkannya
secara kolektif sebagai sistem tunggal
asalkan semua
sistem diukur.
Sebagai contoh sederhana, katakanlah kita punya dua
bit X dan Y dan secara kolektif mereka berada dalam keadaan probabilistik
ini di sini,
yang kita lihat sebelumnya. Secara natural, jika kita mengukur
kedua bit ini, kita akan mendapatkan hasil 00
artinya nol untuk pengukuran pertama dan nol untuk pengukuran kedua dengan probabilitas setengah dan kita akan mendapatkan hasil 1,1
WEBVTT
dengan probabilitas setengah juga. Itu cukup jelas.
Pada dasarnya, mengukur semua sistem setara dengan mengukur
seluruh sistem gabungan.
Namun jika kita tidak mengukur semua
sistem, tapi sebaliknya kita hanya mengukur
beberapa sistem, maka situasinya tidak
begitu jelas langsung terlihat
dengan membatasi perhatian kita sekali lagi pada kasus hanya dua
sistem untuk melihat inti dari apa yang terjadi dengan
pengaturan sesederhana mungkin.
Kita bisa mengajukan pertanyaan berikut, misalkan kita punya dua sistem, X dan Y yang bersama-sama sebagai pasangan
dalam suatu keadaan probabilistik tertentu.
Apa yang terjadi jika kita mengukur
hanya X dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y?
Nah, kita bisa menjawab pertanyaan ini menggunakan teori probabilitas dasar.
Pertama, kita tahu bahwa probabilitas bahwa pengukuran
memberikan hasil tertentu harus diberikan oleh rumus ini
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita bisa memikirkan probabilitas untuk setiap keadaan klasik
dari pasangan XY seolah-olah kita memang mengukur keduanya dan kita menjumlahkan semua probabilitas
yang konsisten dengan X berada dalam keadaan klasik
a apapun yang kita minati.
Jadi itulah mengapa jumlah di sini hanya atas keadaan klasik b dari Y.
Salah satu cara untuk memikirkan
rumus ini adalah bahwa probabilitas untuk melihat keadaan klasik tertentu dari X jika kita mengukurnya
harus konsisten dengan probabilitas untuk melihat keadaan itu jika
kita juga mengukur Y, meskipun kita tidak,
itu sangat natural dan intuitif. Probabilitas untuk pengukuran X menghasilkan hasil tertentu mungkin bergantung pada apakah Y
juga diukur
terlepas dari hasilnya.
Jadi itu memberitahu kita apa
probabilitas untuk berbagai kemungkinan
hasil pengukuran, tapi apa yang terjadi pada Y atau
pengetahuan kita tentang Y sebagai hasilnya?
Jawabannya adalah bahwa masih
bisa ada beberapa ketidakpastian tentang keadaan Y sebagai
hasil dari pengukuran X
dan melihat hasil tertentu. Dan ketidakpastian itu direpresentasikan oleh rumus ini di sini untuk probabilitas bersyarat
bahwa Y berada dalam beberapa
keadaan klasik b tertentu, diberikan bahwa X berada dalam beberapa keadaan klasik,
keadaan klasik a apapun,
yang kebetulan kita ukur.
Lebih tepatnya, probabilitas bahwa Y berada
dalam beberapa keadaan klasik b, diberikan bahwa X berada dalam keadaan klasik a,
sama dengan probabilitas
bahwa X berada di a dan Y berada di b dibagi dengan probabilitas bahwa X
berada dalam keadaan klasik a.
Jadi jika kita mengukur X, kita akan melihat
keadaan klasik yang berbeda dengan probabilitas yang ditentukan
oleh rumus ini di sini
dan tergantung pada hasil yang kita dapatkan, kita mungkin masih punya beberapa ketidakpastian tentang keadaan klasik dari Y dan
ketidakpastian itu tercermin
oleh rumus ini di sini.
Sebenarnya ada cara yang sangat mudah
untuk mengungkapkan ulang semua ini dan untuk melakukan perhitungan
untuk kasus-kasus spesifik menggunakan notasi bra-ket
dan cara kerjanya seperti ini.
Kita mulai dengan menuliskan
keadaan probabilistik dari XY sebagai vektor seperti ini, dan
ini sepenuhnya umum.
Entri-entrinya dilambangkan oleh Pab dan ini bisa berupa angka apa pun selama seluruh vektor
adalah vektor probabilitas.
Kita bisa menyatakan ket ab sebagai
tensor product seperti yang kamu lihat di sini dan kemudian kita bisa menggunakan
sifat bilinear dari tensor product
dan khususnya fakta bahwa ia bersifat linear dalam argumen kedua untuk menyatakan vektor ini
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Yang kita lakukan adalah secara efektif mengisolasi vektor-vektor basis standar
di sisi kiri dan menempatkan apapun yang kita butuhkan
di sisi kanan
untuk memungkinkan itu karena itu akan mengungkapkan apa yang terjadi ketika kita
mengukur sistem pertama X.
Khususnya probabilitas
untuk mendapatkan hasil tertentu a adalah jumlah atas semua probabilitas yang muncul dalam
tanda kurung di sebelah ket a.
Dan dikondisikan pada mendapatkan
hasil tertentu a, vektor probabilitas yang menggambarkan ketidakpastian apapun yang tersisa tentang Y
adalah vektor yang berada di
tanda kurung di sebelah a.
Kecuali bahwa kita harus menormalisasinya untuk menjadikannya vektor probabilitas dan itu artinya kita harus membagi vektor itu
dengan jumlah entri-entri dalam vektor itu untuk membentuk vektor probabilitas.
Di sini omong-omong, jumlahnya diambil atas semua
c dalam gamma alih-alih b hanya untuk menggunakan nama variabel yang berbeda sehingga tidak akan ada kebingungan
tentang cakupan variabel-variabel
jika kamu mau.
Jumlah di pembilang
dan penyebut harus dianggap sebagai hal yang terpisah dan kita bisa menghindari kemungkinan kebingungan tentang itu
dengan menggunakan variabel yang berbeda
untuk dua jumlah tersebut.
Ini adalah contoh cepat untuk
mengilustrasikan bagaimana semua ini bekerja.
Misalkan XY adalah sepasang bit dalam keadaan probabilistik ini di sini untuk memahami apa yang terjadi
ketika kita mengukur bit pertama
dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada yang kedua, kita menulis vektornya seperti yang kamu lihat di sini di mana ket nol dan ket
satu dalam posisi pertama
diisolasi sama seperti yang
kita jelaskan beberapa momen lalu.
Kemungkinan pertama adalah
bahwa hasil pengukuran adalah nol dan probabilitas
dari itu terjadi adalah jumlah probabilitas
di dalam tanda kurung
WEBVTT
yang di-tensor ke ket nol. Jadi kita mendapatkan satu per dua belas ditambah satu per empat, yaitu sepertiga dan
dikondisikan pada hasil nol.
Keadaan probabilistik dari Y
menjadi vektor ini yang dinormalisasi atau setara dibagi dengan probabilitas
yang baru saja kita hitung, dan jadi yang kita dapatkan adalah
vektor ini di sini.
Kemungkinan kedua adalah bahwa hasil pengukuran adalah satu dan perhitungannya
dilakukan dengan cara yang serupa menggunakan suku kedua dalam ekspresi
alih-alih suku pertama. Dan jika kamu ingin memverifikasi detailnya, silakan seperti biasa jeda video untuk memberi dirimu sesaat untuk melakukannya.
Kamu bisa melakukan jenis perhitungan yang sama untuk mengetahui apa yang terjadi ketika
Y diukur alih-alih X.
Metodenya sama hingga suatu simetri antara dua sistem.
Kali ini kita menulis
vektor probabilitas seperti ini, mengisolasi vektor-vektor basis standar di sebelah kanan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
tapi cara kerjanya sama persis.
Kamu juga bisa menggunakan metode ini
untuk lebih dari dua sistem.
Bisa sedikit berantakan hanya untuk menuliskan semua ekspresi yang diperlukan, tapi secara konseptual idenya
persis sama.
Akhirnya, untuk bagian pelajaran
tentang informasi klasik, kita akan melihat operasi-operasi
pada keadaan probabilistik
dari beberapa sistem. Mengikuti penalaran yang sama yang sudah kita lihat beberapa kali.
Kita menyimpulkan bahwa operasi probabilistik pada beberapa sistem adalah sama
seperti operasi probabilistik pada sistem tunggal yang direpresentasikan
oleh matriks stokastik.
Tapi kali ini matriks-matriks itu
punya baris dan kolom yang bersesuaian dengan Cartesian product dari himpunan keadaan klasik sistem-sistem individual.
Yaitu kita sekadar
memandang sistem gabungan seolah-olah itu sistem tunggal dan jatuh kembali pada deskripsi tentang bagaimana operasi probabilistik bekerja
untuk sistem tunggal dari
pelajaran sebelumnya.
Ini adalah contoh dari operasi yang disebut operasi controlled-NOT
pada dua bit X dan Y.
Ini sebenarnya adalah operasi deterministik dan cara kerjanya adalah
bahwa jika X sama dengan satu, maka operasi NOT dilakukan pada Y
dan jika tidak, jika X sama
dengan nol maka tidak ada yang terjadi.
Bit X kadang-kadang
disebut bit kontrol karena ia menentukan apakah
atau tidak operasi NOT diterapkan ke Y
dan Y disebut bit target karena itu adalah bit yang dikenai oleh operasi NOT.
Kamu juga bisa membayangkan
menukar peran X dan Y sehingga Y menjadi bit kontrol
dan X menjadi target, tapi itu adalah operasi yang berbeda
dari yang dijelaskan di sini karena operasinya tidak
simetris antara X dan Y.
Keduanya disebut
operasi controlled-NOT, dan kita hanya perlu menentukan
mana di antara bit-bit yang merupakan bit kontrol dan
mana yang merupakan bit target.
Operasi ini punya aksi
yang kamu lihat di sini pada keadaan-keadaan basis standar dan kamu bisa memeriksa
aksi itu terhadap definisi
dari operasi tersebut. Dan ini adalah representasi matriks dari operasi tersebut.
Ketika kita memikirkan operasi ini, kita bayangkan bahwa ada
dua bit terpisah ini dan mereka memainkan peran yang baru saja saya jelaskan dengan
X sebagai bit kontrol
dan Y sebagai bit target, tapi sebenarnya tidak ada yang
tentang aksi ini di sini atau representasi matriks ini
yang menuntut kita untuk
memikirkan dua bit ini sebagai bit-bit terpisah.
Kita bisa juga sekadar
memikirkan operasi ini sebagai operasi deterministik
pada sistem yang punya empat keadaan klasik
yang telah kita putuskan untuk diberi nama
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 dan 1,1.
Ini adalah contoh lain dari
operasi probabilistik pada dua bit, yang kali ini bukan
operasi deterministik.
Operasi tersebut menetapkan Y sama dengan X dengan probabilitas setengah dan jika tidak itu berjalan ke arah lain dan menetapkan X sama dengan Y.
Operasi ini tidak punya nama khusus itu hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
Dan ini adalah representasi matriks dari operasi ini.
Kamu bisa melihat bahwa itu bisa dinyatakan sebagai rata-rata dari dua matriks, satu yang merepresentasikan operasi deterministik
di mana Y ditetapkan ke nilai apapun
yang disimpan dalam X dan yang lainnya yang menetapkan
X sama dengan Y.
Jadi di sini kita melihat bahwa kita bisa mengambil rata-rata dari matriks stokastik untuk mendapatkan yang baru sama seperti yang kita punya di pelajaran sebelumnya.
Sekarang, mari kita pertimbangkan
pertanyaan berikut. Misalkan kita punya dua
operasi probabilistik masing-masing pada sistemnya sendiri
yang dideskripsikan seperti biasanya oleh matriks stokastik
dan lebih tepatnya, katakanlah M adalah
operasi probabilistik
pada sistem X dan N adalah
operasi probabilistik pada sistem Y.
Pertanyaannya adalah jika kita
secara bersamaan melakukan M pada X dan N pada Y, bagaimana kita menggambarkan
efek yang ini miliki
pada sistem gabungan XY?
Memikirkan ini
secara intuitif sesaat, jika kita secara bersamaan
melakukan dua operasi pada sistem masing-masing mereka,
maka kita sebenarnya
melakukan operasi pada sistem gabungan, jadi itu harus dideskripsikan
oleh suatu matriks stokastik.
Jawaban singkat untuk
pertanyaan ini adalah bahwa matriksnya diperoleh dengan mengambil tensor product, bukan antara vektor seperti
yang kita bicarakan sebelumnya,
WEBVTT
tapi antara matriks dalam
kasus ini, matriks M dan N.
Jadi mari kita luangkan beberapa momen
untuk mendiskusikan tensor product dari matriks dan kemudian kita akan
kembali ke pertanyaan ini.
Ini adalah definisi
dari tensor product antara matriks dan
itu sangat analog dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Jika kita mengasumsikan bahwa dua
matriks yang kita kerjakan ditulis dalam bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini sehingga entri-entri dari M dilambangkan dengan alpha ab saat a dan b
merentangi beberapa himpunan keadaan klasik sigma dan entri-entri dari N dilambangkan oleh beta cd saat c dan d
merentangi beberapa himpunan keadaan klasik gamma.
Maka produk dari M dan N adalah matriks yang kamu lihat tepat di sini.
Yang kita punya mirip
dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Baris dan kolom dari M tensor N bersesuaian dengan pasangan keadaan klasik yang ditulis sebagai string di sini,
dan entri-entrinya adalah produk dari entri-entri yang bersesuaian dari M dan N.
Ini adalah cara lain untuk menulisnya dalam hal entri-entri individual
dari matriks-matriks ini.
Entri ac bd dari M tensor N adalah produk dari entri ab
dari M dan entri cd dari N.
Ada cara lain untuk
mendeskripsikan M tensor N, yaitu ia adalah
matriks unik yang mengubah setiap vektor berbentuk Phi tensor Psi
menjadi tensor product dari M yang diterapkan pada Phi dengan N yang diterapkan pada Psi, dan itu harus benar untuk setiap pilihan
dari vektor-vektor Phi dan Psi ini.
Salah satu cara untuk memikirkan
ini adalah bahwa tensor product dari matriks berjalan sempurna dengan tensor product antara vektor.
Ini adalah persamaan yang
secara natural kamu harapkan benar dan memang begitu.
Dalam hal matriks yang
ditulis secara eksplisit, kita bisa mendefinisikan tensor product seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ada banyak titik dalam persamaan ini dan mereka dimaksudkan untuk
mengilustrasikan polanya, yang merupakan pola yang sama
yang kita punya untuk vektor kecuali sekarang kita punya baris dan kolom
sebagai lawan dari sekadar vektor kolom.
Kalau belum jelas, contoh
berikut mungkin membantu.
Di sini kita membicarakan
tensor product dari dua matriks dua kali dua.
Kita pertama menuliskan empat
salinan dari matriks kedua, satu untuk setiap entri dari matriks pertama.
Kita mengalikan masing-masing
salinan dari matriks kedua dengan entri yang bersesuaian
dari matriks pertama,
dan kemudian kita kumpulkan semuanya menjadi
satu matriks empat kali empat seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita juga bisa mendefinisikan
tensor product dari tiga atau lebih matriks dengan cara yang analog dan mungkin cara termudah untuk menyatakannya
adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini
di mana kita punya rumus untuk setiap entri dari tensor product, yang sekadar merupakan produk
dari entri-entri yang bersesuaian.
Kamu juga bisa mendefinisikan tensor product dari tiga atau lebih matriks secara rekursif dalam hal tensor
product dari hanya dua matriks seperti yang kita punya untuk vektor.
Dan satu catatan terakhir adalah
bahwa tensor product dari matriks bersifat multiplikatif, yang berarti bahwa
produk dari tensor product
sama dengan tensor product
dari produk-produknya.
Kamu bisa memikirkan
ini sebagai generalisasi dari rumus dari beberapa momen lalu untuk aksi dari tensor product dari matriks
pada tensor product dari vektor. Dan sekali lagi, ini adalah sesuatu yang
tentunya kita harapkan benar dan kita bisa bersyukur bahwa itu benar
dan kita akan memanfaatkan fakta ini
kapanpun kita butuhkan.
Dan sekarang kita bisa kembali ke
pertanyaan dari sebelumnya yang menanyakan bagaimana kita mendeskripsikan
efek dari melakukan operasi M pada sistem X
dan operasi N pada sistem Y bersama sebagai operasi
pada sistem gabungan XY.
Dan jawabannya untuk
pertanyaan itu adalah bahwa aksinya dideskripsikan oleh
tensor product dari M dan N.
Tensor product merepresentasikan independensi kali ini antara operasi-operasi sebagai lawan dari apa yang kita lihat
sebelumnya untuk vektor probabilitas.
Ini adalah contoh cepat. Misalkan kita melakukan
operasi probabilistik yang dideskripsikan oleh matriks ini pada bit X.
Ini kebetulan adalah operasi
yang kita lihat di pelajaran satu dan kita secara bersamaan melakukan
operasi NOT pada bit Y.
Operasi gabungan pada pasangan XY karenanya direpresentasikan oleh tensor product dari matriks yang bersesuaian dengan dua operasi ini.
Ini adalah yang pada X dan
ini adalah operasi NOT pada Y dan kita mendapatkan matriks
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan kamu bisa melihat bahwa memang
ini adalah matriks stokastik dan itu akan selalu terjadi.
Tensor product dari dua
matriks stokastik manapun atau berapa pun jumlah matriks stokastik
akan selalu stokastik.
Ini adalah situasi yang sangat umum
bahwa kita menemukan situasi di mana satu operasi dilakukan
pada satu sistem dan tidak ada yang dilakukan pada sistem lain.
Dalam situasi ini, kita mengikuti resep yang sama persis dengan pemahaman bahwa tidak melakukan apa-apa direpresentasikan oleh matriks identitas.
Misalnya, jika kita punya dua bit X dan
Y dan kita mereset bit X ke keadaan nol, yang sama halnya
dengan melakukan fungsi nol konstan
pada X dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y, maka operasi yang dihasilkan pada pasangan XY
WEBVTT
direpresentasikan oleh tensor product ini
di sini.
Semua ini menggeneralisasi
ke berapa pun jumlah sistem dan kita akan melihat beberapa contoh tambahan ketika kita beralih ke konteks kuantum, yang bekerja dengan cara yang persis sama
kecuali bahwa kita punya matriks uniter alih-alih matriks stokastik, dan itu sudah cukup tentang
informasi klasik untuk sekarang.
Sekarang kita akan mengalihkan perhatian
ke informasi kuantum dan bagaimana ia bekerja untuk beberapa sistem.
Polanya sama seperti
untuk informasi klasik.
Kita bisa memandang beberapa sistem kuantum sebagai sistem gabungan tunggal dan menerapkan apa yang kita tahu
dari pelajaran sebelumnya.
Sekali lagi, tensor product
akan memainkan peran kunci dan secara keseluruhan kita mendapatkan deskripsi tentang bagaimana informasi kuantum
bekerja untuk beberapa sistem.
Yang sangat analog
dan secara matematis mirip dengan apa yang baru saja kita lihat untuk
informasi klasik.
Kita akan mulai dengan keadaan kuantum.
Keadaan kuantum dari beberapa sistem direpresentasikan oleh vektor kolom yang punya entri bilangan kompleks
dan norma Euclidean sama dengan satu
sama seperti keadaan kuantum
dari sistem tunggal.
Kali ini indeks-indeks
dari vektor keadaan kuantum bersesuaian dengan Cartesian product dari himpunan keadaan klasik
dari sistem-sistem individual
karena sekali lagi, itulah
himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem gabungan.
Misalnya, jika X dan Y adalah qubit, maka himpunan keadaan klasik
untuk pasangan XY bersama adalah Cartesian product dari
alfabet biner dengan dirinya sendiri,
yang bisa kita pikirkan sebagai
himpunan semua string biner dengan panjang dua.
Jadi vektor-vektor yang kamu lihat di sini semuanya adalah contoh dari vektor
keadaan kuantum dari XY.
Jika kita mau, kita bisa juga menulis
vektor-vektor ini seperti ini di mana kita punya ket terpisah
untuk setiap qubit
di mana tensor product
di antara mereka tersirat.
Atau kita juga bisa menulis
simbol tensor product secara eksplisit seperti ini jika kamu lebih suka.
Dan pilihan lainnya adalah
memberi subskrip pada ket-ket dengan nama sistem
yang mereka representasikan seperti ini.
Dan kamu bisa melakukan ini dengan
simbol tensor product atau tanpa.
Itu terkadang sangat membantu untuk menjaga kejelasan.
Ini hanyalah gaya-gaya yang berbeda untuk menyatakan vektor-vektor yang sama dan kita bisa memilih mana yang kita mau atau mana yang kita lebih suka atau
mana yang paling masuk akal
untuk situasi yang ada. Ketika sesuatu menjadi lebih
rumit misalnya, kita mungkin memutuskan bahwa salah satu
gaya ini menambah kejelasan
dan kita bebas untuk membuat
pilihan apapun yang kita mau.
Tensor product dari vektor-vektor keadaan kuantum juga merupakan vektor keadaan kuantum.
Untuk kasus dua sistem misalnya, jika Phi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
dari sistem X dan Psi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
dari sistem Y,
maka tensor product dari Phi dan Psi adalah vektor keadaan kuantum dari XY.
Kita menyebut keadaan-keadaan seperti ini product state dan mirip dengan apa yang kita lihat dalam konteks probabilistik klasik, mereka merepresentasikan independensi
antara sistem X dan Y.
Jadi misalnya, jika seseorang punya laboratorium
di satu bagian dunia dan mereka membuat sistem X dan menginisialisasinya ke keadaan kuantum Phi
dan orang lain di
bagian dunia lainnya secara independen menginisialisasi sistem Y ke keadaan kuantum Psi,
maka jika kita memilih untuk memikirkan XY sebagai membentuk satu sistem meskipun itu dua bagian di bagian dunia yang berbeda,
maka sistem gabungan XY berada
dalam keadaan Phi tensor Psi.
Semua ini menggeneralisasi ke
lebih dari dua sistem dengan cara alami.
Jika kita punya keadaan kuantum
Psi1 hingga PsiN dari sistem-sistem terpisah Xn hingga Xn, maka tensor product dari n vektor ini
merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum, yang sekali lagi disebut product state dari sistem gabungan X1 hingga Xn.
Ini adalah contoh dari
keadaan kuantum dua qubit.
Meskipun mungkin tidak
langsung terlihat. Ini adalah contoh dari product state karena kita bisa menulisnya
sebagai tensor product seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jadi ini adalah contoh dari
product state terlepas dari bagaimana ia ditulis, yang relevan adalah apakah
atau tidak mungkin untuk menulisnya sebagai tensor product.
Keadaan kuantum ini, bagaimanapun, yang sekali lagi adalah keadaan dua
qubit bukan merupakan product state.
Ini mirip dalam semangat dengan
contoh yang kita lihat dalam konteks probabilistik dari dua bit acak yang berkorelasi sempurna
dan argumen yang sama menunjukkan bahwa itu tidak bisa ditulis
sebagai tensor product.
Jadi mari kita pindahkan ini ke sini dan mari kita lihat argumennya secara sedikit lebih detail.
Bayangkan bahwa kita
bisa menulis keadaan ini sebagai tensor product dari
dua vektor Phi dan Psi.
Entri yang bersesuaian
dengan keadaan klasik 0,1 adalah nol untuk vektor ini, yang bisa kita lihat hanya dengan melihatnya.
Ini akan menyiratkan namun demikian, jika vektornya adalah tensor product dari dua vektor bahwa entri nol dari Phi
kali entri satu dari Psi
akan sama dengan nol, tapi itu berarti bahwa entah
entri nol dari Phi atau entri satu dari Psi sama dengan nol
atau keduanya bisa sama dengan nol, tapi itu bertentangan dengan fakta
bahwa dua produk di sini harus keduanya bukan nol.
WEBVTT
Mereka sama dengan satu
per akar dua. Argumennya sebenarnya hampir
identik dengan apa yang kita punya dalam konteks probabilistik.
Tidak ada yang secara unik
kuantum tentang hal ini sama sekali.
Bagaimanapun juga, yang kita temukan adalah bahwa keadaan aslinya bukan product state.
Perhatikan bahwa tidak penting
bahwa dua angka di sini adalah satu per akar dua.
Yang penting adalah bahwa
kedua nilai bukan nol.
Keadaan kuantum tertentu ini
adalah keadaan yang sangat menarik. Ini adalah contoh dari
keadaan yang ter-entangle dari dua qubit.
Kita akan lebih banyak membahas
entanglement nanti dalam seri ini.
Entanglement bisa rumit, khususnya ketika kita
membicarakan keadaan kuantum dalam formulasi umum
dari informasi kuantum,
tapi di sini dalam deskripsi yang disederhanakan dari informasi kuantum, entanglement setara dengan ketiadaan independensi.
Jadi untuk vektor keadaan kuantum,
jika itu bukan product state, itu adalah keadaan yang ter-entangle
dan keadaan tertentu ini
umumnya dipandang sebagai
contoh arketipe dari keadaan kuantum yang ter-entangle.
Dan sebenarnya, kita kadang-kadang
memikirkan keadaan ini sebagai merepresentasikan satu unit entanglement, khususnya ketika kita
memikirkan entanglement
sebagai sumber daya yang bisa
digunakan untuk melakukan hal-hal menarik.
Keadaan kuantum yang
baru saja kita bicarakan adalah salah satu dari empat keadaan yang disebut bell state, yang bisa kamu lihat di sini
beserta nama-nama
yang umumnya digunakan untuk keadaan-keadaan ini, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus dan Psi minus.
Semuanya ter-entangle
dan mereka memang membentuk basis untuk ruang semua
vektor yang merepresentasikan keadaan dari dua qubit.
Jadi empat vektor ini bersama-sama
disebut Bell basis.
Ini adalah koleksi keadaan kuantum yang sangat sering
ditemui yang dinamai
untuk menghormati John Bell, yang adalah fisikawan yang membuat
kontribusi sangat penting
untuk studi entanglement di tahun 1960-an.
Berikut adalah beberapa contoh terkenal dari keadaan kuantum tiga qubit.
Yang pertama disebut GHZ state.
Ini semacam seperti keadaan Phi
plus yang baru saja kita lihat kecuali untuk tiga qubit alih-alih dua.
Dan contoh kedua disebut W state dan terlihat seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, jadi ia seragam atas
tiga string biner
dengan panjang tiga yang punya
tepat satu bit yang diset ke satu.
Tidak ada dari keadaan-keadaan ini yang merupakan product state dan keduanya punya properti yang menarik dan muncul cukup sering sebagai contoh, jadi bagus untuk diketahui
dan kita akan melihat mereka lagi.
Selanjutnya kita akan membicarakan tentang
pengukuran sistem dalam keadaan kuantum.
Mengikuti penalaran yang sama
yang telah kita ikuti sejauh ini dalam pelajaran, yaitu memikirkan beberapa sistem
seolah-olah mereka adalah sistem tunggal. Kita segera sampai pada deskripsi tentang bagaimana pengukuran
dari beberapa sistem kuantum bekerja
asalkan semua
sistem diukur.
Yaitu jika kita punya
vektor keadaan kuantum Psi yang merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum
dari n-tuple sistem
X1 hingga Xn dan kita mengukur
seluruh sistem gabungan, yang setara dengan mengukur
setiap sistem individu, maka setiap n-tuple yang mungkin
dari keadaan klasik akan menjadi hasil pengukuran
dengan probabilitas yang sama dengan
nilai absolut kuadrat dari entri Psi yang
bersesuaian dengan n-tuple itu.
Misalnya, jika kita punya
pasangan sistem XY dalam keadaan kuantum ini di sini, maka jika kita mengukur kedua sistem,
maka kita akan mendapatkan hasil nol hati artinya nol untuk pengukuran X dan hati untuk pengukuran Y
dengan probabilitas sembilan per dua puluh lima dan kita akan mendapatkan hasil satu
sekop dengan probabilitas enam belas per dua puluh lima.
Itu cukup jelas. Kita pada dasarnya mengabaikan fakta bahwa ini adalah dua sistem terpisah dan kita memandangnya seolah-olah
mereka satu sistem tunggal,
tapi ini memunculkan
pertanyaan alami berikut, yang sudah kita pertimbangkan
dalam konteks klasik.
Misalkan kita punya dua sistem X dan Y yang secara kolektif
berada dalam beberapa keadaan kuantum dan kita tidak mengukur keduanya, tapi
kita hanya mengukur satu sistem.
Katakanlah kita mengukur sistem X dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y.
Tentu saja, kita juga bisa bertanya apa yang terjadi jika kita mengukur Y dan bukan
X dan lebih umum apa yang terjadi jika kita punya
tiga atau lebih sistem
dan kita mengukur beberapa subset yang tepat dari mereka. Tapi begitu kita punya
jawaban untuk pertanyaan ini, kita akan punya jawaban untuk
pertanyaan-pertanyaan itu juga.
Kita tahu bahwa secara umum
vektor keadaan kuantum dari pasangan XY mengambil
bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini, dengan mengasumsikan seperti biasanya bahwa sigma dan gamma
adalah himpunan keadaan klasik
dari X dan Y masing-masing.
Entri-entri dari vektor ini dilambangkan oleh alpha ab yang merentangi semua kemungkinan pilihan dari a dan b,
dan mereka bisa berupa bilangan kompleks apa pun yang menyebabkan vektor ini
menjadi vektor satuan.
Sekarang kita sudah tahu bahwa jika
kedua sistem diukur, maka kita mendapatkan probabilitas untuk berbagai kemungkinan hasil
WEBVTT
dengan mengambil nilai absolut kuadrat dari entri yang bersesuaian.
Dan jadi jika hanya X yang diukur, maka probabilitas untuk
mendapatkan hasil tertentu a diberikan oleh ekspresi ini,
kita sekadar menjumlahkan semua
kemungkinan hasil b, yang bisa diperoleh
jika Y juga diukur meskipun tidak.
Idenya sama seperti dalam
konteks probabilistik.
Probabilitas untuk mendapatkan
hasil tertentu ketika X diukur tidak mungkin
bergantung pada apakah atau tidak Y juga diukur.
Jadi ini memberitahu kita apa
probabilitas untuk berbagai kemungkinan hasil.
Selain itu, akan ada beberapa
perubahan dalam keadaan Y sebagai hasil dari telah
melakukan pengukuran pada X dan mendapatkan hasil tertentu.
Jadi mari kita lihat bagaimana ini bekerja.
Mirip dengan apa yang kita lakukan dalam
konteks probabilistik, kita bisa menyatakan
vektor keadaan kuantum Psi seperti yang kamu lihat di sini
di mana Phi a adalah vektor ini untuk setiap pilihan keadaan klasik a dari sistem X,
kita menggunakan sifat bilinear
dari tensor product seperti sebelumnya.
Hanya sekarang kita telah memilih untuk memberi nama
vektor-vektor yang berbeda ini Phi a, hanya untuk kenyamanan.
Kita sudah mengamati bahwa probabilitas bahwa pengukuran menghasilkan
setiap kemungkinan hasil a adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
tapi sekarang kita bisa melihat bahwa probabilitas ini sama dengan norma Euclidean
kuadrat dari vektor Phi a,
dan sekarang sebagai hasil dari pengukuran X yang menghasilkan hasil tertentu a, kita punya bahwa keadaan kuantum
dari sistem gabungan XY
menjadi keadaan ini yang
kamu lihat di sini.
Sama seperti yang kita punya untuk sistem tunggal, keadaannya runtuh pada dasarnya, tapi tidak runtuh
sepenuhnya secara umum,
ia hanya runtuh sejauh yang diperlukan agar konsisten
dengan pengukuran X yang menghasilkan hasil a.
Keadaan kuantum dari Y menjadi Phi a yang dinormalisasi artinya kita
membagi dengan norma Euclidean-nya
sehingga menjadi vektor satuan. Ini analog dengan apa yang terjadi dalam
konteks probabilistik di mana alih-alih membagi
dengan norma Euclidean,
kita membagi dengan jumlah
dari entri-entri Phi a untuk mendapatkan vektor probabilitas.
Tapi di sini karena kita
membicarakan keadaan kuantum, kita membagi dengan norma Euclidean
untuk mendapatkan vektor keadaan kuantum.
Mari kita lihat beberapa contoh untuk melihat bagaimana ini bekerja
untuk keadaan spesifik.
Ini adalah keadaan yang akan kita pertimbangkan. Kita mengasumsikan bahwa X dan Y adalah qubit dan mereka berada dalam keadaan Psi tertentu ini.
Dan katakanlah X diukur.
Kita mulai dengan menuliskan keadaan
Psi seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, secara efektif mengisolasi
faktor-faktor basis standar dari X
dan me-tensor mereka dengan apapun yang kita butuhkan untuk mendapatkan keadaan aslinya.
Sama seperti dalam
deskripsi umum dari tadi.
Probabilitas untuk mendapatkan hasil nol adalah norma Euclidean kuadrat
dari vektor ini di sini.
Hal yang kita tensor ke ket nol dalam ekspresi kita dari vektor Psi.
Dan jadi probabilitasnya adalah tiga per empat dan dikondisikan pada
mendapatkan hasil nol.
Keadaan kuantum dari
pasangan XY menjadi ini di mana kita menormalisasi vektor yang di-tensor ke ket nol,
dan itu setara dengan
membagi dengan akar kuadrat dari probabilitas yang
baru saja kita hitung.
Kita kemudian bisa menyederhanakan
dan inilah yang kita dapatkan.
Probabilitas untuk mendapatkan
hasil pengukuran satu dihitung dengan cara yang serupa.
Kita mengambil norma Euclidean kuadrat
dari vektor ini di sini. Hal yang di-tensor ke ket
satu dalam ekspresi kita dari Psi
dan probabilitas yang dihasilkan
adalah satu per empat, yang harus demikian tentu saja, karena probabilitas-probabilitas kita
harus berjumlah satu.
Dalam kasus ini, keadaan kuantum dari XY menjadi ini di mana sekali lagi kita menormalisasi dengan membagi dengan norma Euclidean
sehingga kita mendapatkan vektor keadaan kuantum ini sebagai hasilnya.
Metode yang sama digunakan
dengan cara yang simetris, jika Y diukur alih-alih X.
Ini adalah vektor keadaan kuantum aslinya, dan kali ini karena Y
diukur alih-alih X,
kita menyatakan vektor Psi
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, di mana kali ini kita mengisolasi vektor-vektor basis standar dari Y
alih-alih X yang di-tensor
dengan apapun yang kita butuhkan untuk mendapatkan ekspresi dari Psi.
Melalui perhitungan, yang bisa kamu periksa dengan
menjeda video jika kamu mau.
Kita melihat bahwa probabilitas
untuk mendapatkan hasil nol adalah delapan per delapan belas kali ini, dan ini adalah vektor keadaan kuantum
yang dihasilkan dikondisikan
pada mendapatkan hasil itu.
Dan probabilitas untuk mendapatkan
hasil satu adalah tiga per delapan, dalam kasus mana ini adalah
vektor keadaan kuantum kita.
Kamu bisa menggunakan metode yang persis sama jika kamu punya lebih dari dua sistem dan subset yang tepat dari mereka diukur.
WEBVTT
Dan ada contoh
dalam konten buku teks untuk pelajaran ini yang bisa
kamu cek jika kamu tertarik.
Singkatnya, kita selalu bisa membagi sistem menjadi dua koleksi terpisah, yang diukur
dan yang tidak.
Dan begitu kita melakukan itu, kita jatuh kembali pada metode
metode yang baru saja saya jelaskan, dan itulah cara pengukuran untuk beberapa sistem kuantum bekerja.
Dan sekarang akhirnya, kita beralih ke operasi uniter
pada beberapa sistem.
Menggunakan ide dasar yang sama bahwa beberapa sistem bisa dipandang sebagai sistem gabungan tunggal.
Kita menyimpulkan apa yang kamu lihat
tertulis di sini di layar, operasi kuantum pada sistem gabungan direpresentasikan oleh matriks uniter
sama seperti yang kita punya untuk sistem tunggal dan khususnya baris dan kolom dari matriks uniter tersebut bersesuaian dengan Cartesian product
dari himpunan keadaan klasik dari kumpulan
sistem apapun yang kita bicarakan.
Misalnya, jika kita punya sistem X
yang keadaan klasiknya adalah satu, dua, dan tiga dan Y adalah qubit,
maka matriks yang kamu lihat di sini adalah contoh dari matriks uniter yang merepresentasikan
operasi pada pasangan XY.
Detail tentang bagaimana kita
mengurutkan Cartesian product yang kita bicarakan sebelumnya tidak terlalu penting untuk
kepentingan contoh ini, itu hanyalah matriks enam kali enam
yang kebetulan uniter.
Tidak ada yang istimewa tentangnya, meskipun ia dibangun dari
beberapa matriks penting.
Intinya adalah bahwa kamu bisa
memilih matriks uniter enam kali enam mana pun dan itu akan merepresentasikan
operasi uniter pada XY.
Jika kita menerapkan kumpulan
operasi uniter secara independen masing-masing pada sistemnya sendiri, maka aksi dari semuanya bersama
pada sistem gabungan diberikan
oleh tensor product.
Dan di sini di layar kamu bisa melihat pernyataan yang lebih tepat
dari fakta itu.
Jika operasi uniter kita dideskripsikan oleh matriks uniter U1 hingga Un satu untuk setiap sistem kita,
maka aksi gabungan
pada sistem gabungan diberikan oleh tensor product dari U1 hingga Un.
Sekali lagi, mirip dengan apa yang kita punya dalam konteks probabilistik, contoh penting adalah bahwa
kita menerapkan beberapa operasi uniter
U ke sistem X dan kita tidak
melakukan apa-apa pada beberapa sistem Y lainnya.
Operasi pada XY yang kita dapatkan adalah U yang di-tensor dengan matriks identitas.
Matriks identitas
menggambarkan tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y.
Terkadang sangat membantu untuk menulis secara eksplisit bahwa matriks identitas ini
bersesuaian dengan sistem Y, hanya untuk membuat rumusnya lebih jelas.
Dan satu opsinya adalah memberi
matriks identitas subskrip seperti ini yang menunjukkan sistem yang ia tindaklanjuti.
Ketika sudah cukup jelas, kita biasanya tidak
repot-repot dengan subskrip, tapi ketika sesuatu menjadi lebih rumit, itu bisa sangat membantu.
Dan kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan
kasus simetris di mana beberapa operasi uniter
V diterapkan ke Y dan tidak ada yang dilakukan ke X,
dan kali ini operasi uniter yang dihasilkan
pada XY, direpresentasikan oleh tensor product ini di sini.
Dan sekali lagi, kita bisa menempatkan subskrip pada
matriks identitas jika itu membantu.
Berikut adalah beberapa contoh spesifik.
Jika X dan Y adalah qubit dan kita
melakukan operasi Hadamard pada X dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y, kita mendapatkan matriks yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jika sebaliknya, kita melakukan operasi Hadamard pada Y dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada X, urutan tensor product dibalik.
Dan jadi kita mendapatkan matriks
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Tidak setiap operasi uniter
pada sistem gabungan bisa dinyatakan sebagai tensor product.
Jika kita punya tensor product,
maka kita punya independensi.
Dan ada beberapa
contoh fundamental dari operasi yang tentu saja
tidak bertindak secara independen pada beberapa sistem.
Misalnya, jika X dan Y punya
himpunan keadaan klasik yang sama, yang bisa berupa
himpunan keadaan klasik sigma manapun,
maka kita bisa memikirkan operasi
swap pada pasangan XY.
Operasi ini tidak mengubah urutan dua sistem, kita masih punya X di
kiri dan Y di kanan, tapi sebaliknya ia merepresentasikan
pertukaran isi
dari dua sistem. Di sini kamu bisa melihat itu dinyatakan
dalam bentuk persamaan di mana kita punya
tensor product dari dua keadaan kuantum.
Cara lain untuk menulisnya adalah sebagai
matriks seperti yang kita lihat di sini.
Cara kamu bisa memikirkan
deskripsi ini adalah bahwa ia memberitahumu apa yang terjadi untuk vektor-vektor basis standar.
Dan begitu kita tahu apa yang terjadi
untuk vektor-vektor basis standar, kita tahu apa yang terjadi untuk
keadaan kuantum arbitrer melalui linearitas,
yang sebenarnya juga berlaku untuk
ekspresi ini di sini.
Jadi operasi tertentu ini di sini kebetulan merupakan operasi deterministik sekaligus operasi uniter.
Jika X dan Y adalah qubit, misalnya, kita mendapatkan representasi matriks ini di sini.
Berikut adalah koneksi yang menarik
antara operasi swap dan empat Bell state, yang ditunjukkan di
sini untuk kenyamanan.
Operasi swap membiarkan
tiga dari mereka tidak berubah, tapi ia meletakkan tanda minus di
depan keadaan Psi minus,
WEBVTT
jadi ada sesuatu yang
istimewa tentang yang itu.
Kamu bisa memeriksa persamaan-persamaan ini secara langsung dengan melihat vektor-vektor ini dan mempertimbangkan apa yang terjadi
untuk keadaan-keadaan basis standar
menukar dua keadaan klasik untuk tiga Bell state pertama
tidak melakukan apa-apa, kita mendapatkan keadaan yang sama dengan yang kita mulai.
Dalam kasus keempat namun demikian, tanda minus secara efektif
berpindah dari satu suku ke suku lainnya ketika kita melakukan swap dari keadaan-keadaan klasik,
dan itu setara dengan mengalikan vektor dengan minus satu.
Jadi melakukan operasi swap entah bagaimana mengeluarkan tanda minus
dari Bell state keempat ini.
Kita akan lebih banyak membahas
persamaan-persamaan ini nanti, tapi sekarang mari kita beralih ke
tipe operasi lain, yaitu operasi terkontrol.
Kita akan mengasumsikan bahwa X adalah qubit dan Y adalah sistem apapun yang kamu inginkan.
Jika U adalah operasi uniter pada Y, maka operasi controlled U pada XY adalah operasi yang
dinyatakan di sini.
Pertama, menggunakan notasi bra-ket dan kemudian menggunakan apa yang
disebut matriks blok, bayangkan mengisi matriks yang lebih besar ini
dengan yang lebih kecil di mana nol-nol ini benar-benar merepresentasikan matriks
yang terisi nol.
Jadi masing-masing dari empat blok ini merepresentasikan matriks yang punya
jumlah baris dan kolom yang sepakat dengan jumlah
keadaan klasik dari Y.
Gagasan tentang operasi terkontrol, yang sudah kita temui
dalam konteks klasik ketika kita membahas
operasi controlled NOT,
adalah bahwa jika X diset ke nol,
maka tidak ada yang terjadi pada Y.
Tapi jika X diset ke satu,
maka U diterapkan ke Y.
Jadi X disebut qubit kontrol, dan Y disebut sistem target, yang secara umum tidak
harus berupa qubit.
Untuk contoh spesifik,
yang baru saja saya sebutkan, kita punya operasi controlled NOT.
Jika qubit pertama diset
ke nol, tidak ada yang terjadi. Dan jika qubit pertama diset ke satu, maka operasi NOT atau setara,
operasi sigma X diterapkan
ke qubit kedua.
Dan ini adalah representasi matriksnya.
Kita membicarakan dua qubit di sini, jadi kita bisa juga memutuskan bahwa qubit kedua adalah kontrolnya dan
qubit pertama adalah targetnya.
Untuk mendeskripsikan operasi tersebut, kita cukup menukar urutan
dalam tensor product, dan hasilnya adalah matriks
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jika alih-alih operasi controlled NOT, kita mempertimbangkan operasi controlled sigma
Z atau controlled Z.
Kita mendapatkan representasi matriks ini di sini. Dan untuk yang ini, sebenarnya tidak masalah
mana yang menjadi kontrol dan mana yang menjadi target.
Kita mendapatkan hasil yang sama bagaimanapun juga.
Kita bisa melangkah lebih jauh dan kita bisa mempertimbangkan operasi controlled swap.
Dan di sini kita
membicarakan pertukaran dua qubit, jadi kita akhirnya punya tiga qubit ketika kita menyertakan qubit kontrol.
Representasi matriksnya
terlihat seperti ini.
Ini adalah operasi yang cukup istimewa dan dikenal sebagai operasi Fredkin, atau lebih umumnya Fredkin gate.
Ketika kita memikirkannya
sebagai gate dalam circuit, kita akan mendiskusikan circuit di pelajaran berikutnya.
Contoh terakhir adalah operasi controlled
controlled-NOT, yang sekali lagi merupakan
operasi pada tiga qubit.
Dan ini adalah representasi matriksnya. Operasi ini jauh lebih dikenal
sebagai operasi Toffoli atau Toffoli gate.
Kita akan membahasnya lebih lanjut
dan kita akan melihat mengapa baik ia maupun operasi Fredkin adalah operasi yang sangat penting
dalam pelajaran berikutnya.
Dan itulah akhir dari pelajaran kedua. Dalam pelajaran ini, kita mendiskusikan bagaimana informasi kuantum bekerja untuk beberapa sistem.
Semoga kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran ketiga segera, yang membahas circuit kuantum,
protokol, dan permainan.
Sampai jumpa.